hey everyone its micromotor flows I'm
excited to tell you about a webinar
coming up on Tuesday January 15th about
how to automate order flow analysis now
one of the questions I've been getting
for years is how can I automate order
flow analysis you know people always
want to automate things to make their
life simpler so I reached out to Pablo
module from the indicator market and
together we're going to do a webinar to
show you how to automate order flow
analysis now what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to show you a quick video showing
the order flows trader and Pablo's tool
which is called markers plus and
honestly it's an amazing tool for
testing strategies and settings and most
importantly for me automating entry and
exits now I'll admit you know I am NOT a
machine sometimes I'm a little bit slow
on order entry and I kicked myself I
I've just you know I'm almost 50 and you
know I'm not a computer
I'm not born in the matrix I don't have
a chip in my head or anything like that
so sometimes I I'm a little bit slow on
entry and it does cost me does cost me a
few ticks here and there and with order
flow analysis you know admittedly
there's a lot of information to digest
so by telling the computer what to look
for I then let the computer enter the
trade for me now I'm free to analyze the
order flow after I'm in the trade to
manage it you know I'm a big believer in
managing your trades you know I don't
always just let the trade go to the take
profit or stop me out I don't believe in
that you know if things change in the
market you know conditions always change
once you're in a trade and if the
conditions tell me to get out I get out
if they tell me to stay in the trade I
stay in now this is going to be a quick
video just to show you the capabilities
of markers with the order flows trader
now I've sped it up for sake of time so
just give me a second here okay so this
is the order flow trader software and
I've have this footprint sped up at
about 30 times the speed and I just want
to show you how easy it is to implement
markers with order flows trader now
honestly there is a learning curve you
know it's not something you just gonna
plug in and it's just going to start to
you could just you know plug and play
you do have to play around with settings
but you know I'm trying to make it a
little bit easier for you I'm trying to
create a bunch of templates which you
know if you are interested and you have
some of my tools and you have Pablo's
tool that
it will make life a lot easier for you
okay actually I have it sped up at fifty
times rather than I had a thirty
originally but it seemed a bit slow
actually I think fifty might be love it
slow but anyway you know I want you to
see how you know the footprints are for
me no because you know for me like I
said earlier trade management is very
important you know I'm not a person that
says oh my gosh you know there's a
signal I have to take it and I have to
let it go to the stop price or the take
profit price you know everything's
changing in the markets you know new
buyers are coming in new sellers are
coming in and you know while I believe
that you know order flow is the you know
the best way to trade you know people
will disagree with me but you know if I
see something in the order flow that's
you know that's a red flag saying hey
get out of this trade I'm gonna take it
I'm gonna get out of that trade rather
than you know leave myself exposed there
so you can see here you know as I'm
talking the order you know conditions in
in the Delta I'm using this with Delta
scalper were triggered and you know it
automatically enters my stop price now
you know I could I thought wanted to I
could move the stop you know up you know
up here whoops
there we go or you know I could move the
the limit up or down whichever way I
want to go you know I want I could also
just close out the trade right in here
how you could close you know if I think
I know maybe I get a little bit more out
of this trade based on you know
something happening in order fo you know
I'm a big believer that if if the trade
isn't starting pay off pretty soon you
know I'll scratch it if I can or make a
small profit but you know I see now
starting to come up towards my my exit
no it's coming back down you know I have
my my ATM already pre entered in here at
my my e-mini ATM you know you could set
your own ATMs you know your your auto
trade management target okay so you know
they're you're not gonna move my target
higher if I thought there was a reason
to you know sometimes you see the market
really catching a head of steam and you
know there's just a lot of things you
can do with this amazing software so you
know if you're interested in watching
this webinar I suggest you just register
for it first I mean that's the thing
that you got to do you go to in the link
below in the description there's going
to be the signup link okay honestly
right now I've got about 400 people
signed up it's this a Sunday afternoon
and we're doing it on Tuesday there is a
space limit of 500 I'm gonna contact
GoToWebinar see if they could expand it
for me but um okay here I just got into
another trade okay you see how it's just
managing you know like I said you know
if I wanted to move my take profit I can
move it up like that you know if I want
to move my stop I could lose my stop up
yeah you know if I want to just exit the
trade now you know like I didn't I could
hit close and it would close it out
right and hit that so again you know go
to the link below in the description and
sign up you know I'm looking forward to
seeing you on the presentation and see
how that
you know my software Pablos software can
help you turn that corner in your
trading to become a better trader so
thanks everyone and I'll see you on
Tuesday bye bye